- Yeah, it's awesome,
and then I can hear, like...
[muffled noises]
and then like a...
and a... [muffled noises]
[rhythmic muffled moaning]
And I'm like,
"This'll fucking do, man!
Yeah!"
[motorcycle roaring]
[animalistic roar]
[dark electronic music]
♪
- Welcome to
"This Is Not Happening."
I'm your host, Ari Shaffir,
and today the topic is crime.
[cheers and applause]
One of the original members
of The Grawlix,
please give it up--
right down here beside us--
Mr. Ben Roy, everybody!
- So I had to go
to my buddy's wedding,
and it's in Connecticut,
'cause that's where
all amazing divorces start,
is in Connecticut,
and I end up at this--
they put me up, they
put--because my buddy is not--
doesn't have a lot of money.
They put us all up at a fucking,
like, a Motel 6,
and yeah, it's bullshit.
It's the worst,
and there's no pornography
at all.
For like five straight days,
no pornography.
My wife says,
"How does a Motel 6
not have pornography?"
How does a Hyatt Regency have--
you know what,
if you have a hotel,
you should have porn
graded to the level
of hotel you have.
Now, if you got
a Hilton Garden Inn,
yeah, pipe it into the room
through Pay-Per-View,
but if I'm at a Motel 6,
there should be at least
like a rusty, little lockbox
under the sink
that's filled with, like,
Delia's catalog cutouts
that have been culled
from the neighborhood kids
at the hillsides or something,
but there's fucking nothing,
and I'm drinking too much,
on top.
Like, I'm just getting
hammered the entire time,
and I'm just--I am a mess,
and I keep going out
and getting drunk,
and then I come back
and I'm jerking off
to everything I can find on TV.
I mean, I start with,
like, exercise infomercials,
and then I just get
more and more degrading,
like, as it goes, like,
then I start watching
foreign channels,
'cause you know
they'll show nudity,
but then I'll sit through
a Spanish subtitled
fucking 6 1/2 hours
of "Sense and Sensibility"
for one Kate Winslet nipple
that never comes,
and so I'm just miserable.
Then I'm watching
scrambled channels
thinking it's pornography,
and it's never porn.
You're like--you're like,
"That's a clit.
That's a clitoris right there."
and then the screen straightens
and you've just been jerking off
to a very robust
cartoon bear nose
or something like that.
So I'm, like, just getting
real depraved with it
and I--and I come back one night
and I'm real low and drunk,
and it's cold, and wet,
and I'm in my jacket,
and I sit on the edge
of the bed,
and I hear the holy grail
of all things in that moment
which is that the couple
in the room behind me
are going the fuck at it.
That is--that's
fucking gold, right?
That's the--that's as good
as pornography right there.
Like, and it's aggressive.
Like, I can hear it
just muffled.
Like, I can hear, like...
[muffled noises]
And I can--yeah, it's awesome,
and then I can hear, like...
[muffled noises]
and then like a... and a...
[rhythmic muffled moans]
and I'm like,
"This'll fucking do, man!
Yeah!"
I'm like, "Dude, I can do this."
So I get, like, real fevered.
I start--I just
pull my pants off complete--
my underwear, but I leave
my jacket on.
I'm real excited
about all of it,
and I don't take my shoes off.
It gives me traction
'cause I can push back
into the bed, right?
And then I widen my legs
out real wide,
bud, all right,
get them real wide
for better sexual
reception, right?
So it acts like a satellite dish
and just--
I sit there, and I'm pumped now.
I'm real hard, and then I decide
I'm just gonna start,
and I start with
a slow, honeymoon jerk
because I don't want to go
too quick.
I want to savor it, right?
So I start with just
a slow top to bottom
but I'm already into it,
and so I just--I start going.
I'm ice chiseling.
I'm really getting
into it, right?
I'm carving myself
out of ice right now.
Like, I'm really going to town
like I'm one of those
old cigarette machines that
just ate all of my quarters.
I'm really just...
[violent grumbling]
Come on!
You know what I mean,
and I'm just, I'm going,
and then after a minute
it's not doing it.
This isn't doing it.
It's not enough,
as it is with most dudes.
So I decide that I bet
that if I get up on the bed
and I press my ear to the wall,
now I can hear details.
So with my boots--
my shoes still on,
still in my jacket,
I get up on the bed
and I put my foot up on the--
the headrest, and I lean my ear
against the wall,
and I can hear it clear as day,
and I'm laying real still
to not pull my ear
off the wall, right?
And now I'm jerking it
like this.
I looked like
the most disconcerting
little army green man
in the package.
Like, one that shouldn't
have been made.
Real controversial, right?
So now I'm going to town,
and I'm really going at it,
and I'm like, "Oh, yeah,
this is so fucking good."
[moaning]
Oh, oh, oh, oh, God.
Oh, God.
And then I realize
these two aren't having sex.
This guy...
is beating the shit
out of this woman.
[scattered laughter]
Fuck you!
Fuck--I'm not condoning
domestic violence.
I'm masturbating to it,
and those are two fucking
totally different things.
Every guy will tell you
that we masturbate
to shit we don't condone
all the time,
and I know this isn't right.
I'm aware of that,
but I'm fucked here
because what do I do?
Seems like an easy decision
with your rose-covered
hindsight glasses on,
doesn't it?
But I'm in a bad situation
because if I don't come,
okay, if I stop right now, okay,
then I got to go to
a wedding tomorrow morning
in terror alert red, okay?
There's requisite couples
dancing.
There's polyester pants.
I'm bound to get an erection
with my buddy's mom
and there's no way
to hide that at all.
You ever try to hide
an erection?
Every detail comes out
in polyester.
It looks like Han Solo frozen
in carbonite, okay?
So I'm fucked,
but then if I don't stop--
and my grandmother was right,
and someone's really gonna
get hurt by my masturbation.
So here's what I decide.
It's late at night,
and I realize
that there are always,
like, there's never anybody
at the front desk
at these hotels, right?
I bet that I can
pick up the phone,
press it to my ear,
finish the job, right,
before she picks up,
effectively killing
two gooey birds
with one stone, right?
So here's what I do.
I pick up the phone.
I press it to my ear.
I hit zero.
I start going, and I'm going--
she picks up like that,
immediately,
and I'm the middle of coming,
and all I can get out is...
[breathy]
"There's trouble in 318."
[laughter and applause]
[moaning]
Oh, shit.
Now, any guy will tell you
that the minute you come,
you are thrust back
into the full weight
of whatever situation you're in
because come is just fantasy
condensed down
to a liquid format,
and then you heave it
from your body.
So instantly I was like...
"What the fuck am I doing?
Holy shit."
Oh--and all kinds of weird stuff
starts going through your head
in that moment.
Like, you think weird things.
Like I was like,
"I hope that
Truman Show shit isn't real."
Holy--we just lost a bunch
of sponsors tonight,
I can tell you that much.
So that night they, like,
they, like, knocked on my door.
I didn't answer.
The cops did,
after they broke it up
and they split them apart
and everything,
and, uh, in the morning,
uh, the day--
I went through the lobby,
and, uh, the manager was there
and he's like,
"I'd like to thank you
"for calling the police.
We'd like to comp your room."
[chuckles]
And I said yeah.
I did.
I took it,
but really what I wanted
to say was,
"No.
"No, you charge me twice...
"Once for me and...
once for the part of myself
I left in that room."
You guys are awesome.
Thanks.
My name's Ben Roy.
Have a great night.